david hallyday voulait échapperait pas
une interview fils de david et l'idée
est ce que comme guillaume depardieu il
vous est arrivé de détester votre père
non non jamais est ce que comme ari
boulogne vous êtes déjà demandé qui
était vraiment votre père oui voyez ça
m'est arrivé oui encore aujourd'hui des
fois quand et comment est ce que comme
jésus vous est arrivé de vous prendre
pour le fils de dieu non non non est ce
que comme laura smet vous avez eu envie
de prendre un autre nom oui vous appelez
de la vie de se mettre à un moment non
bien sûr
non mais je me suis en fait c'est un
truc qui m'a toujours suivi depuis je
suis né en fait ouais j'ai découvert
qu'on m'avait appelé david à l'idée
d'aider que dès que je suis ça m'a suivi
toujours est ce que comme michael
douglas j'avais l'impression d'avoir
relevé le flambeau
non est ce que comme emmanuelle béart
vous pensez que vous réussirez à faire
oublier votre père c'est vraiment pas
une question que je me pose
la réponse aurait ici non non non est ce
que comme charlotte gainsbourg ça vous
embête ray de ressembler à votre père en
vieillissant encore une offre vite
magnéto serge je vous emmènerai de
ressembler à mon père non mais je pense
qu'on se ressemble déjà beaucoup de gens
là beaucoup de ressemblances france il
ya plus beau c'est vrai
je sais pas beaucoup plus je ne sais pas
mais c'est gentil libyen csq comme
claude chirac vous avez encore beaucoup
d'ambitions pour votre père a bien sûr
bien sûr mais je pense qu'on ne cesse
d'évoluer puis deux
on n'a jamais fini le travail qu'on a
commencé toute manière est ce que comme
anthony delon vous êtes rendu compte que
le talent n'était pas héréditaire mais
le talent le talent n'est pas
héréditaire j'aime bien anthony 5 mx
mais moi aussi
oui ben dis donc qu'est ce que ce serait
là il a dit qu parce que c'est il l'aimé
pas est ce que comme paul belmondo vous
ai déjà fait honte à votre père volant
d'une voiture de course
non est ce que comme salomé lelouch vous
pensez que votre beau-père était avec
votre père différent
un différend différents c'est bien
d'avoir ni des beaux parents différents
shows tu apprennes des trucs différence
c'est plutôt pas mal
s comme chiara mastroianni vous n'osez
pas dire à votre mère le prendre sa
retraite
jamais jamais jamais parce qu'on
n'arrête pas les passions et tant qu'on
est passionné ça ça passe soit ça passe
bien est ce que comme claude françois
junior faisait déjà pensé à faire fils
de votre père comme métier
moi c'est pas facile non non ça déjà été
assez compliqué d'être moi donc est ce
que comme julie depardieu votre père
faisait déjà embrassé en public
oui oui messieurs ça vous a gêné
oui il avait mis la langue aussi
galli della loggia melsat et mika et
oui mesdames messieurs
voilà on a tous vu l' écoute on a fait
un tour global la base un tap a appelé
sa copine j'aurais pas nécessité sur un
on peut l'appeler non également d'un mec
un peu le portable de sa pa bizarre pour
de gros coup ce soir
ouais tu sais ce qu'elle fait là non pas
du tout non avais tu lui fais confiance
ouais ouais ouais je suis ce genre de
mec si on souhaite c'est le début
janvier le far west c'est toujours au
début on fait ce qu'on va qu'on puisse
te quitter mois david qu'on puisse qu'on
puisse être méchant avec toi qu'on
puisse te quitter c'est vrai mais moi je
te laisserai pas tomber
c'est vrai mais elle est une et pas ou
peu
toujours dans un coin de la tête c'est
un peu une fille il a bien entendu c'est
super difficile à vivre
ouais c'est peut-être une teigne me
voici peut-être bien défaut d'y aller
faut bien des faux cta par exemple moi
un du range je range ouais c'est bizarre
parce que j'étais super bordélique petit
puis après ça s'est arrangé ils
s'entendraient bien que moi j'aime bien
les gens que c'est aussi un bien c'est
marrant je mets 10 d'or à droite du lit
ouais j'ai pas vraiment de côté et toi à
moi c'est à droite moi mais s'il a pas
de côté ça va en avoir bien avec toi
mais qu'est ce qui se passe ce soir
visite à une écoute mon dieu ces gens
dont on va s'arrêter parce que sinon ça
va mal tourner et puis voilà mettre mal
à l'aise
ah non je suis pas mal du tout d'abord
le problème tu veux qu'on fasse une
pause bisous alors